let's talk some football there's plenty
of football to talk about even though
the top story continues to be the top
story
aaron rodgers isn't talking but now
current teammates are specifically
current
teammates specifically devante adams
he did some media rounds yesterday
and uh he he
initially said he's behind aaron rodgers
100
okay fine he's your quarterback of
course you're going to be behind him 100
percent
what are you going to say i completely
disagree with what he's doing
i object to how he's conducting his
business that wouldn't help
that wouldn't be useful teammates
support teammates quarterback
subscribers
receiver receiver supports quarterback
that part of it i wasn't surprised
by it all i'm behind him 100 i would
expect most of his teammates to say that
if they were asked about it on the
record
yeah well i i agreed i mean that's kind
of like common code right with your
teammates in the locker room your work
mates whatever it is you're always going
to try to
be that good teammate good support
friend like
hey i'm behind you with what whatever
you got to deal with in business i'm
here to support you
so that is part of it but i mean of
course
i think there's more to it than just
that because
yeah they got a special connection
devonte adams and rogers has been really
special the last three years last year
it might have been the most special
combination in football
i mean devonte adams he doesn't want to
see aaron rodgers leave
he knows that's going to be a huge part
of where his legacy goes from here
whether aaron rodgers is there what they
can continue to do
and can they continue to have years
where he gets 15 18
you know receptions and all those things
and even with devante adams mike i'll
just say this too
like he's he he's
even though he plays receiver he
realizes they haven't given him the
greatest support in the world
as far as aaron rodgers and honestly
mike i bet you
devonte adams at times a little bit like
hey i wouldn't mind if we got a robin in
here do
you know i'm batman and get me a robin
get a number two guy
take some pressure off of me so the
bright lights aren't always on me in big
games to take me away
so he understands i think the situation
in totality and of course like you said
he's going to support his guy
or another batman i mean ty or another
batman that's right
you're right batman and batman is better
than batman and robin it is it
definitely is yes two batman's beating
batman and robin no doubt
no you're right but i think he probably
realizes that you know
again we've gone over this a few times i
feel like recently it's come up
organically but like
batman robin batman batman whatever you
go through the great receivers in
football and history
they had another guy there with him you
know jerry rice had john taylor he was
damn good
i mean tory holt and isaac bruce marvin
harrison
and reggie wayne so it's not like
there's not enough footballs to go
around to get these guys catches
so i think devonte adams probably
realizes the big picture there too to go
wait
they're not supporting rogers now
they're messing up my future here
and what i can do as far as getting a
legacy here in the nfl
and he probably also realizes wait we're
not capitalizing on what we could really
be in
a greatest show on turf type of offense
with this quarterback and me at receiver
and do all those things
he probably feels like they're leaving
some potential out there every year too
another thing that devonte adams said
and this reminds me of the report last
week
from mike garafolo of nfl media that
aaron rodgers was
telling teammates who were due to become
free agents
hey i may not be here well aaron rodgers
after
or excuse me davonte adams after 2021 is
due to become a free agent
so regardless of what aaron rodgers said
last year enough is happening now that
devonta adams needs to factor roger's
presence into his future that's my guy
that's the only guy i've had except for
the 2017 season when he got hurt
that's the only guy i've played with and
we've built up a special connection over
the years and it's put us both in
really good positions in our career not
that he needed me to come along for it
because he was already in that
spot and there's more we established a
lot together
yeah it would change a lot it doesn't
mean potentially i would be gone but i
definitely would do some extra thinking
if my guy wasn't here yeah because you
want to go to a place maybe where your
guy is
right maybe if your guy is in denver
that's where you want to go or if he
goes to the raiders that's where you
want to go or he goes to some other team
maybe that's where you want to go the
familiarity
is transferable from one team to the
next
otherwise you're getting started from
scratch for jordan love and they still
don't know
what's happening exactly that's why they
can't move on
the jam of the packers said after the
first day of the draft
that that that jordan love has a long
way to go
they just look no preseason last year
limited reps
didn't play at all last season they
don't know what he can do devonte adams
doesn't know what he can do right
none of these guys know what he can do
and and
and and he may get thrust into the
starting lineup
if aaron rodgers isn't there i i gotta
think that's one of the things that you
know panics the packers as of right now
and why
you know they definitely would want
rogers back this year
just because yeah there's a there's a a
huge
you know flashing light microscope
whatever you want to talk about on the
jordan love
pick and green bay the front office of
course right mike i mean
they want to make sure when he does play
it
goes in the right direction it starts
off on the right foot
they're going to be judged by his
success so now
he's coming off a year where there was
no otas no rookie mini cams nothing like
that
no you know weird training camp no
preseason football
so what the hell is he right now yeah
guten koost
mark murphy and company they they don't
want to throw out a guy there that they
feel like is that a ready
product yet right because that's just
going to end up being more critical in
their life and everything about what
that pick was and everything there so
you're right that's another huge issue
here for the packers is the fact that
they don't have a guy that they can just
go
well we can make it do i mean i know
they can make it do
but they don't want to make a do with a
first round pick that they traded up to
get
and have gotten themselves in this
situation they want him to like hit the
ground running and go look
this is why we got rid of the other guy
he this guy really can be something and
i'm sure that jordan love is not there
yet devonte adams also appeared with
peter king on
his podcast here is a question from
peter about aaron rodgers and what
devante adams had to say in response
what's been your reaction in the last
couple of weeks to
the the stories about aaron wanting out
um i mean it's been tough man it's you
know i've obviously spoke to him a
little bit
um can't really share too much of what
we talked about but um
you know it's just something that you
know part of this business is
you got to keep people happy um and it's
tough because you know you have so much
time invested in one place and you've
done so much for one place you just kind
of
hope to see that that respect uh um
you know reciprocated i guess you could
say and
when it doesn't work out exactly how you
want you have issues like this but
we're just being positive and you know
i'm just sticking to my training doing
what i have to do to put myself in a
position to be ready
whoever my quarterback is um come season
hope we're praying that it's still
airing
um just so we can continue what we what
we've had going this whole time
but uh yeah just just gonna continue
working to see how it plays out
do you have a gut feeling whether he
will be a packer this year or not
i don't man just trying to be positive
keep my mind on i don't even want to
you know bring anything else into this
universe i just want to thank good
thoughts and
um kind of downplayed in my head and
just hope that you know
at some point just goes back to normal
then we show up to camp and everybody's
ready to rock
boy he prefaced all that by saying i
talked to him and there isn't much i can
say and then he said plenty
a lot right he said a lot without
attributing it to aaron rodgers but the
information that he shared with peter is
information that necessarily comes from
his interaction with aaron rodgers and
the idea that
he doesn't have a gut feeling that in
and of itself is a wow
right you have you don't and and and i
get the sense
he's trying not to let himself indulge
whatever gut feeling may flow from the
information he has
because that gut feeling could be this
guy's gone
right he doesn't want that he doesn't
listen to that part of the gut right
i don't i don't want i don't want to
pursue
this feeling i have that
if push comes to shove he's not going to
be here and yeah this is the guy who
last week said got to appreciate what
you got while you got it
and aaron rodgers clicked the like
button on that tweet
and look part of what adams also said it
confirms the existence of
an issue you hope to see respect
reciprocated when you say that in this
context
it confirms that aaron rodgers feels
disrespected by the organization why
because they traded up last year to
draft jordan love without telling him
and put him on a year-to-year
arrangement where they hold all the
cards and they decide after 2020 2021
2022
yeah we continue to it just it confirms
everything
what devante adams said to peter king in
response to two questions even though
adams
was trying to be very careful and
circumspect and guarded in what he
shared directly from aaron rodgers what
he shared indirectly
confirms everything chris
a hundred percent and you know that's
the
maybe another aspect we haven't really
talked about when you hit on this like
subject and there's there's a lot of
course different angles
but that's an aspect that i feel like
maybe i haven't paid attention to
the locker room is going to be on aaron
rodgers
side the players are going to be as much
as hey they might
whatever there's probably a few that
think hey he's a baby or he complains
too much or whatever
it doesn't matter and the nfl
aaron rodgers is a guy that even whether
you like him or
not he's got enough pelts on the horses
the wall
whatever general patches our army com i
mean he's got it all
you you you respect that guy and you
give him the respect
and players in a lot of patches i don't
know what the hell
i don't have you know the things that
they put on there to give them
is that what they're called is that what
they're called i don't even know
great yeah medals yes metals sure metal
sounds
good those metals are good i like the
medals yes
but you don't you don't do that to a guy
like aaron rodgers especially not like
yeah he's not in the prime of his career
but it's not like coming to an end as
we've talked about so many times
so he's gonna have all the players
looking through a devante adams
you know lens that we just heard where
it's like
hey the you know you hope to get the
respect that you get you know you give
and you hope to get that back yeah
that's what he's referring to
players are going to be they're going to
be on roger's side with this
because they're going to feel he's been
wrong so rogers probably has very good
support within the locker room
especially from the guys who are
responsible to
catch the passes he throws it because he
retains
a wide degree of discretion as to where
he's going to throw those passes not
that he has a ton of
great options other than devante adams
still that's his guy those guys are tied
together
and they've lived it they've seen it
they surely had the same what the hell
are the packers doing
right exactly right when when they know
how close they are yeah after the 2019
season right
to being a super bowl team a first round
pick and a fourth round picker packaged
together to go up and get a guy who best
case scenario will never play
that's the best case scenario because we
have aaron rodgers
why are we doing this at the quarterback
position
you know peyton manning never had a
backup
like that the best quarterbacks don't
need backups like that now the patriots
did a little bit with tom brady and it
worked
stir the pot a little bit but never a
first rounder no so
yeah other guys in the locker room are
gonna look at it and they're gonna be
upset too
not as upset as the guy who's in the
middle of it but i'm not surprised adam
supports rogers and my guess is if you
lined up
every guy on the locker in the locker
room yeah and had that same conversation
they would say basically what devante
adams said yeah i
agreed a hundred percent i mean you you
laid it out there perfectly and then
kristen put that graphic back up there
with the wide receiver stats and
everything i mean listen
this is wrong this sheet is wrong
this is not a good look this is if
you're a top tier offense
you don't want to have one guy that says
115 receptions
and then the next guy is a tight end
with 52 receptions
and let me just say out of those 52
receptions i'm gonna say
25 of them are bootlegs where he came
behind the line of scrimmage
and caught the ball one yard deep or in
the flat behind the line of scrimmage
so this speaks to the lack of weapons
and sometimes the diversity and how they
you know feature people within this
offense and it's not just right now this
has been a rogers thing for a while in
green bay
but that that good really good offenses
complete offenses not offenses that are
just good
with a top 10 receiver and the second
best quarterback in football that makes
us think it's great
really good offenses that have a lot of
things as we've talked about
they have more than one guy you have to
focus on
in the pass game and that's where the
packers have done rogers wrong
and adams yeah he loves it and all that
type of stuff but still he's probably
going
wait i could get 115 still if we could
get another receiver in here to get 70
receptions
and be a dangerous guy and do all that
so he's going to continue to stick up
with rogers there's there's no doubt
about that
they have a special thing i can speak
from experience it's not easy to get
that type of chemistry that those two
have
i've never even been on that level but
it is a special thing and you don't want
to give that away for anything
i'm sure that's what devonte adams is
scared of too
for clarity that graphic that we have
shown
is the receivers in tight ends only
aaron jones isn't on there he had 47
catches
yeah 355 yards last year uh and a couple
of touchdowns
so that adds to it it's another weapon
it's another target it's another guy
higher up on the list frankly than
everyone but devonte adams right
that's two yeah receivers everybody's
got running back that you can throw the
football too i don't wanna
i don't wanna understate what aaron
jones does it
for the offense but when you're talking
about receivers and tight ends we talked
earlier about
tyree kill and travis kelsey and they're
doing what they can to invest assets for
a guy like amy cole hardman they hope
byron pringle comes around they found a
way to keep
sammy watkins last year they understand
you need to have an array
demarcus robinson there's no slouch just
can't be the one guy
right who until he gets double covered
and taken away
you just feed him and then you worry
about where you're going to send the
ball once devante adams is blanketed
sufficiently when he's tearing you
up like we've seen him do so many times
so uh
bottom line
the silence continues from aaron rodgers
but we don't need to hear anything from
aaron rodgers at this point
to know there is a very real issue it
isn't going away you know one thing i
noticed though yesterday
that was fascinating to me last week
the packers and the broncos win totals
were taken off
of points bet i checked all the major
sports books last night
the broncos are on at eight and a half
the packers are still
off so i don't know what vegas is
thinking currently
i don't know if vegas it tells me they
have concluded this guy isn't getting
traded
the only question is is he going to play
packers or is he going to sit or go to
jeopardy or do something other than play
football at all
because the broncos are back the packers
are still off
yeah i i guess that's what it is saying
there you're right
you know and and and again i mean like
you said the other day
if this does come to a point where
finally all right both sides have had it
i mean
there's teams that are going to come out
of the weeds here and be interested in
aaron rodgers in a trade market and
trying to figure something out and
anything like that
but man it goes back to the root root
thing here
you know yeah there's issues here
everything like that
but can rogers really get his hands
dirty and get
muddy and everything like that and
really be the jerk that he probably
needs to be to push himself out the door
and also within that you know
sacrificing
uh he's this is different you know than
than peyton manning leaving the colts
where the team was kind of going
downhill
and other things like even brady leaving
the patriots like
this team yeah even though we want them
to have more help they're still
damn good as we've seen and of course he
makes them great and makes them that
super bowl contender
and is he willing to sacrifice and leave
that while he's still
really good and you know playing at the
top of his game
man i don't know that's why i think the
more time goes on here i think rogers is
slowly gonna come back to green bay
and not be and realize that like hey
it's not perfect
but i like the coaches i like the
players i'm damn good still and we can
still be damn good
and screw the front office i'm gonna
play the year
and i'll make a mess of it after the
year's over
but that's why i think they are taking
the position they have
because they believe at the end of the
day that he will
stay away here yeah right right sit out
right he won't pay back
11.5 million to skip this year he won't
give back the 6.8 million he's already
earned in a roster bonus
for this year he won't give up one of
the remaining years of his career
because even if he doesn't play
father time is still going to push him
one more trip around the sun
and he's going to be in a position where
maybe he gets injured maybe the fastball
starts to lose some of it
some of its own maybe it's a little
harder to get to the level of
performance that he had last year
so why is he going to give a year of
that up and and
incur the wrath of the fan base if he
doesn't
show up for and and i look at the points
on the calendar
you've got the is voluntary
but the otas are coming sooner rather
than later does he show up for the otas
that'll be news if he doesn't mandatory
mini camp in june does he show up for
that if he skips that
it's definitely news and it lays the
foundation for a potential training camp
hold out
then you've got the shareholders meeting
in between mandatory minicamp
and training camp there's a lot of
points on the calendar between now and
training camp where we're going to get
some clarity
yeah but i still think that at the end
of the day if he can find
a way to backpedal
and i think that the comments last week
i think so too about this friday the the
john [ __ ] remarks and the james jones
remarks that was the start talk to him
and did speak didn't say oh i can't
speak for him right i feel like they
were surrogates for aaron rodgers to
begin to lay the foundation for him to
eventually say
of course i was going to be here was
there ever any doubt what are you
talking about what's the big deal
why is everybody looking at me what's
why why is everyone concerned about
you know that that that nonsense after
he lights the fuse and the bomb goes off
and he wonders why
you know there's shrapnel everywhere
that that i
i have a feeling yeah that's like a
store right for that kind of uh
of a what's wrong with everybody what
what do you mean i unplugged from social
media for a couple of weeks and look at
everything that's had just some you know
some some not credible bs like what we
heard
in hindsight yeah i want to go back and
watch his interview with pat mcafee two
days after the nfc championship game
knowing what we know now yeah i know all
the efforts of down play
oh oh do you want a new contract oh well
you know we always have conversations
about it yeah we have conversations
about how you want out
of those conversations every year so um
i i'm just i'm bracing for the aaron
rodgers
i don't know why this is a big deal and
then he pivots
and spins it back against us either
specifically or generally
it's our fault for making a big deal
baloney i say in advance
and i'll say after the fact baloney he's
had extended opportunities
to come out and say what's really going
on and his silence
has only caused this to continue to boil
and then devonte adams comments to peter
king perfect example chris
of silence from rogers yeah but talking
privately to someone
someone making it clear that there's an
issue he
he i i was going to say he can't come
out now and say there there wasn't an
issue it's all overblown he can he can
do whatever he wants
but we don't have to believe it we can
say you're full of it pal
and i'm ready to say you're full of it
pal when he tries to do that yeah i know
i feel like we're past that point uh
hopefully he would be smart enough to
realize like he can't go backwards that
way
they can't put the toothpaste back in
the toothpaste holder on that one okay
but if most of the audience
is dumb enough to buy it yeah then you
then you can get away with it well
you're right i mean
hey listen there you're at you're right
and there is an audience out there
that's dumb enough to buy just about
anything right now
but yeah i i am going to be interested
to see how he handles this situation
altogether and you know you bring up the
mcafee thing i don't mean our audience
i don't mean i know you mentioned
because right right i guess
i mean broader yes cheese heads not all
of them but enough of them
yes the ones who would be inclined to be
mad at him if he comes back and says hey
i love all of you i love green bay i'm
not going anywhere their relief will be
enough to get them to believe whatever
it is he has
right and they'll be mad at us for
making a big deal about it and putting
them through these weeks of angst well
he might be mad at us and the media and
say yeah we spend it around i'm going to
be interested to see if i don't care
anymore i'm gonna don't care yeah i
don't think he's gonna be stupid enough
to do that this time around
and i would also say to like you know
the green bay packer fans yeah again
i know rogers hey he's a pain in the
butt and he's caused some issues here
too but what did you expect
what did you expect this is still green
bay's
fault you know i'll go back to something
i heard mike holmgren talking about this
weekend
i mean you got to know your quarterback
and know that like if you make that kind
of move
this is the kind of stuff that could
happen and that's where like i can't
imagine green bay fans being
too mad at rogers when all said and done
when he finally does say he wants to
come back and all that
or or tries to you know mend men this
together but
i want to ask you this mike like back in
january when you brought up that mcafee
thing right
do you think at that time
and i'm just i'm going to give you my
sense i don't know do you think he
really wanted to leave the team at that
point
i think at that point it was more about
just getting the security from the
contract right
and then maybe it's manifested itself to
not get the answers he wanted through
these visits from everybody
to then where it's like okay the hell
with you guys i want out of here
or do you think he was kind of always
like i kind of want out of here from the
get-go even back to the mcafee interview
i think when he said what he said in
january he had the flow chart
in his brain if not reduced to writing
somewhere as to how this is going to go
yeah here's how this is going to go i'm
the mvp of football
you put this guy behind me you trade it
up to get him you're trying to
prod me into becoming a better player so
i have to worry about what you'll do if
i'm not a better player
i'm not going to play that game anymore
here's what we're going to do i'm going
to get a contract that is going to make
jordan love irrelevant it's going to tie
the packers to me i'm tied to the
packers for as long as they want me at
least for three more years
they're not tied to me they can get rid
of me anytime they want
and maybe after one more year they will
i'm no i'm not going to go for that i'm
going to short circuit that so the one
way to do it
is to try to get a new contract that
would bind us together and get them to
admit that they screwed up get them to
maybe trade jordan love
whatever the case may be neutralize that
threat i think that was
one of the points one of the boxes on
the float chart
and if yes they agree problem solved if
no
that's when you continue to further
steps and what whatever the content of
the conversations were whatever prompted
the brain trust to go out there at least
three times
to try to unruffle his feathers and it
didn't work
i i think he knew before he started down
this path
that one of the potential destinations
would be i'm done here
i want out or at least an effort to get
out even if it ultimately on the flow
chart
ends up aaron rodgers staying in green
bay you know the flow chart may have
may have split early but at the end of
the day the flow chart may come back
together with the end result being he
stays in green bay yeah no i mean
yes i mean i i get it i'd understand it
i mean if i'm him i'd probably
i'd err on coming back too i mean this
i'm
you know i'd be going damn i'm too good
we're still
too good even though they haven't
supported me i mean it was we were close
last year and they could have won the
super bowl last year they could have
done it they could have beat the chiefs
in that game and everything like that
with the way
mahomes was hurt everything there i mean
it was there for the taking so
you know the other thing too here like
matt casey our producer who's you know
he's a mets and jets man so he's not
that smart and he's
lack of brain cells but he did
he did oh my god that was completely
gratuitous i know
completely unnecessary oh i feel like it
was very necessary on a tuesday morning
i got to do something alive and me
liven this show up a little get him
going but like
what he he brings up the point with like
even the jeopardy stuff
with rogers was that part of the plan
of like putting pressure on the
situation i mean knowing him and
you know the way you explain it i
wouldn't doubt that either that that was
a little bit of a maybe a planned
approach to put you know
himself out there with the the hosting
stuff too
but think about it we first heard
uh of the issue being a real thing
after he cleared his two-week stint with
jeopardy before that
it was hyping jeopardy and when he made
the media rounds
there was no reason for anyone to say
hey aaron you're thinking about leaving
the packers this year
i mean it did play out perfectly from
the standpoint of
he made multiple appearances aimed at
maximizing the ratings for his two-week
stint at jeopardy oh and it worked by
the way
and then when anderson cooper was
hosting
after aaron rodgers that's when aaron
rodgers
diverts everyone's attention from
jeopardy watch him
don't watch don't watch aaron anderson
cooper
don't watch jeopardy anymore tune in and
watch nfl network and sportscenter owen
peacock by the way pft live at pftpm
uh to find out what's going on with me
and what i'm going to do
so look as i've said many times and i've
gotten some pushback some folks via
email
they think i'm giving rogers too much
credit they think that i'm overstating
his overall intellectual capacity but
when you've
proven that you're extremely smart when
you've won the celebrity tournament on
jeopardy
when you revel in your wonderlic score
in the presence of brett favre and make
fun of him
for his allegedly from the jeff pearlman
biography of brett favre
you're going to be regarded as a smart
guy and people are just going to presume
that there are no coincidences there are
no accidents that everything you do
is the product of careful and deliberate
strategic
thought chris yeah i mean listen he's
got that reputation there's no doubt
he's not
getting rid of that anytime soon and
yeah the fact that
we just have too many instances where it
seems like everything was calculated and
played a certain way to
to not think or at least you know
entertain the thoughts that this was all
planned out and part of a big pr
push and everything like that uh so yeah
i don't know
it's a crazy situation what an unreal
off-season i don't i've never seen
anything like it
franchise quarterbacks dangling from
strings on uh from organizations like
i've never seen before
and i don't know where this is gonna go
but i'm gonna play the i'm gonna play
the bet that he's gonna come to his
senses
realize he's got a coach he likes some
players and team he likes
give the big old middle finger to the
front office on a daily basis
and just go out there and keep throwing
touchdowns and he'll be back with the
packers i just think we've gone
too far down the road now to where i
just don't see a trade or him ending up
on another team at this point happening
i found our post from 2016 after the
brett favre
book came out and and again if you if
you've never read it it's
it it holds up it's you know it's the
story of brett favre
and everything that goes along with
brett favre's experience in the nfl
when when aaron rodgers showed up in
2005 he was bragging that he got this is
all from the book this is all reportedly
this is all from the book i'm not saying
it's factual but i don't think jeff
perlman would have written these things
if he hadn't
vetted it rogers was bragging that he
got a 35 on the wonderlic
and he said brett what did you get i
have no idea farf said
roger said i do i looked it up you got a
22.
and eventually and that that pissed
brett off
yeah and eventually donald driver
packers receiver at the time pulled
rogers aside and said aaron we get it
you're smart now shut the
f up so um so we established way back
you got to put the rookie in this place
yeah yes hi
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports